[MUSIC PLAYING]
BOB LANGERT: One of the things
I often heard in my outreach
to the outside
world is, I didn't
know McDonald's did this stuff.
Like, you work on corporate
social responsibility
at McDonald's.
So I was very motivated to
kind of reveal the story.
I also thought probably the
sweet spot for my audience
is the business community
and the NGO community.
Because companies
today are wrestling
with this idea of how to
serve society and make
a profit at the same time.
And it's not easy.
The battle to do good--
It's a battle.
Everything in
business is a battle.
But certainly doing good
takes a lot of effort.
I thought by writing the book
and sharing the stories of all
these things that went
over the last 30 years--
and let's face it, McDonald's
was the hot rod issue
for so many things--
how we reacted,
who we worked with,
how we solved problems,
how we did not succeed--
I thought all these things would
be worthwhile for the business
leaders today, and the
NGO leaders today that
are trying to make a difference.
DAVID LANGERT: So early on in
the book in the introduction,
you talk about
how the prevailing
wisdom among businesses was
the only responsibility company
had was to be profitable.
But you challenged this
notion early and often
throughout the book.
So why is corporate
social responsibility
and sustainability important
for business like McDonald's
and Google as well?
BOB LANGERT: I
think that's what's
really interesting about the
journey of all the companies
over the last three decades,
really, is that you can't just
make money anymore.
You know, before 10,
20, 30 years ago,
companies were more
punished for not doing good.
I mean, think of Nike, and
sweatshops, or Shell, some
of the instances that they had.
But really, companies
today are seeing
that by responding
to societal issues,
they're bringing value
to their business.
For McDonald's, the data--
we created our own framework
for the future, which was 2014.
The headline was,
"We're going to grow
our business by making
a positive difference
in the world."
And I think that's the
evolution that we've seen,
is that societal
issues don't have
to be a drag on the business.
They don't have to be a risk.
They don't have to be
something to be afraid of.
It's actually what people want.
And consumers want to engage
with companies that care.
And it's the companies
that can figure out
the right formula of doing
what's good for society, what's
good for the company,
that are going
to be the leaders
of tomorrow's world.
Again, it took us a while to
figure that out at McDonald's.
Most of our work at McDonald's,
admittedly, was probably
very reactive at the beginning.
When we were attacked on
waste or animal welfare,
we were like at McDonald's,
hey, we're good people.
We're a good company.
Why are you picking on us?
And we still did
something about it.
But it came from more
of a defensive posture.
So what's really changed--
I think the opportunity today
is that companies should not
be afraid of this.
They should look at this
as like climb the hill.
The more responsible we are in
a smart way, taking smart risks,
we can gain more
customers, more sales.
We can save money.
Better for our brand.
Our people want to work
for a company that cares.
I mean, the business case
for this is absolutely solid.
DAVID LANGERT: You
referenced some
of the battles and some of
the attacks that came on you--
came on McDonald's.
And you had to deal with
a number of critics--
PETA, Greenpeace, the
movie "Supersize Me,"
the book "Fast Food Nation."
So what do you learn about
dealing with this wide range
of critics and activists?
BOB LANGERT: Sometimes I
think the subtitle of my job
was how to deal with
the critics and how
to deal with the people
that maybe didn't like us.
The best thing I learned is that
really, they're not the enemy.
Almost all these groups that
have an interest in companies,
they might come at you
from a negative viewpoint.
They might start a campaign.
But the reality is they're as
passionate about what they're
trying to solve
in the world as we
are in a company
trying to do what
we're doing in the company.
So if you start with this idea
that these outside groups--
I always had the idea that
I'm going to assume innocence,
that the people coming have had
the innocence of saying, hey,
we want you to change.
They might come at us in
a way that we don't like,
but that maybe we
should listen and learn.
To me, the best
example is something--
I mean, I grew up on the South
Side of Chicago, as you know.
[LAUGHS]
DAVID LANGERT: Of course.
BOB LANGERT: And for me to have
an impact on the Amazon rain
forest in Brazil
in my life, I was
like, how did this ever happen?
But real short story.
Greenpeace attacked us.
I think it was 2005.
And it was for too much
soy farming in Brazil
causing deforestation
in the Amazon.
Soy is exported to Europe.
So a bunch of Greenpeace
people showed up
in our restaurants dressed up
as chickens and campaigning
against us.
And so when--
I just love that picture there.
Can you imagine having breakfast
at McDonald's like that?
And I was very
proud of our company
and happy that I was part of the
team that said to Greenpeace,
after we looked at the issue--
we shocked the living
daylights out of Greenpeace
by calling them-- and said,
hey, Greenpeace, we actually
agree with you.
We don't agree
with your demands.
We're not going to change
soy farming overnight
at McDonald's.
We're not into farming.
But if we work together,
we can get other retailers
asking for the same thing.
Cargill is one of our
biggest suppliers.
They're deep into Brazil,
one of the biggest soy
traders in the world.
If we work together,
Greenpeace, how about it?
And to Greenpeace's credit,
instead of campaigning,
we shook hands.
We met in rooms for
a couple of weeks.
We gathered 15 other retailers.
Cargill agreed to help us.
In three months' time, from
the time the campaign started,
this moratorium was put in
place to save the Amazon.
DAVID LANGERT: Wow.
BOB LANGERT: So I
think most people
look at-- oh, Greenpeace.
They're bad, they're the enemy.
No.
And matter of fact, we
took a trip for nine days
through the Amazon.
And I don't think you
could tell the difference
between the McDonald's
people on the trip
and the Greenpeace people.
So it's amazing how much we
have in common with people
that come to us versus what we
have that's maybe not uncommon.
DAVID LANGERT: The organizations
weren't the only folks that
helped you on this journey.
One character that really
jumped out in the book
is Temple Grandin.
BOB LANGERT: Did you like her?
DAVID LANGERT: Oh, I loved it.
Do you mind elaborating
on her and why
she was so important when you
were working with animals?
BOB LANGERT: Well,
you know, if you
had asked me the most
fascinating person
I ever worked with, it
would be Dr. Temple Grandin.
First of all, she's a
renowned animal scientist.
She's probably the most renowned
and respected animal scientist
in the world.
But she's also autistic.
And it makes for a very
special personality.
So my boss gave me the job in--
I think it was like 1998.
He goes, Bob, you've got
to create an animal welfare
program for our suppliers.
I didn't know anything
about animals.
And so I needed to find somebody
that knew about animals.
And Dr. Temple Grandin, I heard,
was the best that there is.
So met her.
She had this idea of creating
an audit system with our meat
suppliers.
And I always remember
the first day
we went into the
first meat supplier.
It's called Lopez Foods.
It's in Oklahoma City.
And we go in there.
I thought I was going
in with Cher or somebody
like that, because Dr. Temple
Grandin was a rock star.
There was people coming
out of the woodwork who
wanted to meet her.
Because she's so highly
respected by everybody.
She's respected by
the animal activists.
She's respected by industry.
So all I did was
channel her ideas.
I matched her up
with our suppliers.
And lo and behold, it
wasn't all that easy.
But over the course of
three to five years,
we implemented leading edge
animal welfare guidelines
and audit procedures for all
the suppliers from McDonald's.
But best yet, you
know, the magic
of working for
McDonald's and what
gave me a lot of satisfaction
is when we did things
for McDonald's,
they ended up being
adopted by everybody in the
industry throughout the world.
So now animal welfare is almost
standard operating procedure,
based on working with
Dr. Temple Grandin.
So everybody should watch
the movie "Temple Grandin."
It's an HBO movie--
Claire Danes.
You'll love her yourself, if
you don't know her by now.
DAVID LANGERT: McDonald's did a
lot of these great initiatives.
But it seems
throughout the book,
they had a struggle to
communicate these efforts
that they're doing.
And it seems to be a common
issue with other companies.
And I can even say
Google, sometimes,
has issues communicating
our efforts as well.
So how does a company
communicate their efforts
in a way that actually works?
BOB LANGERT: One of the main
complaints I got from all
the people that worked for
McDonald's-- because McDonald's
people would know
what we're doing.
We always thought
we were much better
at being a responsible company
than how we were portrayed
in the outside world.
So everybody would come
to me and say, well,
why don't we share more
with what we're doing?
I don't know.
I think there's
two reasons for why
there's a lack of good
communication going on.
One is it is very hard to talk
about the good things you're
doing.
Whenever you open yourself up to
touting something you're doing,
there's always something about
your company or organization
that they can kind of pick on.
So I had a boss
for several years
that said, hey, the strategy
was to get caught doing good,
so not being proactive.
I think the other thing is
companies get under attack.
And like I said before,
a lot of companies.
The natural reaction is to
say the critics are wrong,
the media-- why are you
asking me that question?
And you just kind
of get defensive.
I think the solution
on it is one,
I just think the more
that I see even today
CEOs talking to the public,
it's like corporate speak.
It's not something a human
being would actually say.
So I think one, really work hard
at honest human communication,
as if I'm talking to
my nephew versus trying
to talk to the world.
And then I would say
being open and honest.
And a lot of companies,
they're afraid to do that,
because when you do
that, you have to say,
here's what we do well.
And you also have
to say, well, here's
where we are not doing well.
And I think companies
need to get over that.
Because consumers just want
to see companies trying.
They want to see a commitment.
They don't mind a
lack of progress,
as long as you're trying
hard, and being open about it,
and making steps along the way.
DAVID LANGERT: And this
all leads into the values
that a company has.
And there's a
chapter in your book
where you discuss the challenges
that McDonald's had rolling out
their company values, given
the complexities of it,
the different organizations
within the company
and having global values
when different regions behave
differently.
Can you elaborate on that a bit?
BOB LANGERT: One of my favorite
things that I ended up getting
involved with-- our CEO at the
time-- this is around 2007--
Jim Skinner, one
of our great CEOs--
he really thought as a
legacy for the company,
he could actually more formalize
the values of the company.
So he created these seven values
that you see here right now.
And we ended up being a team
that tried to integrate it
into the business globally.
And we worked on this
for about five years.
To be honest with you, it didn't
go as far as I wanted it to go.
For instance, if you take
a look at the values,
I always thought they
had a little bit too much
formal corporate speak.
First one says we give
back to our community.
So that's what we developed
at the corporate level.
I really like what
Australia did.
We were trying to
make it relevant
in the different markets.
And so Australia said--
DAVID LANGERT: Translation--
we look after the locals.
We grow our business profitably.
And translation is, sure,
we're here to make dollars,
but that's what keeps
85,000 of us in a job.
BOB LANGERT: When Jim Skinner
retired and a new CEO came in,
our values that were
being worked on-- it
sort of fizzled away.
So in some sense,
they didn't last.
Although I'm sure if
we talked to the people
at McDonald's today,
there's values.
And I see it on their website.
But they're not the same values.
DAVID LANGERT: Yeah.
BOB LANGERT: So
you kind of wonder
sometimes how they shift.
So my advice is I think
values are important.
I think there should just
be three or four of them.
I think top management
should always
be referencing the values of
the company any time they can.
I think the people that
work for the company
should be measured
in some degree
by how they live those values.
And that would be, to
me, the ideal world.
And there's no better
way to be a sustainable
company than having
people that live
the values that are the vision.
And I'm not quite sure
what the Google values are,
but how your journey is going.
But that would be my advice for
you as you go on your journey.
DAVID LANGERT: Our values
are on the three respects.
Let's talk a bit about the
internal battles you've faced.
Because it wasn't
always external
where you ran into issues.
Specifically, you were
given an assignment
to create a bold plan for
sustainability in 2020.
Can you talk about that process?
BOB LANGERT: Yeah.
Our number two guy ended up
being our CEO, Don Thompson.
He gave me this
assignment in about 2010
to work on a team to develop a
really bold framework for what
we stand for.
I started working on all
these efforts back in 1988.
So it took how many years?
22 years to finally
get to a point
where the company is saying,
this needs to be strategic.
And he asked me to
come up with a way
to have bold goals
for the future.
So our team worked on it
for quite a long time.
And I came into the senior
management team, the top 20
people in the company.
And they were not seeing a whole
lot of good about the framework
as I was describing it to them.
And they kind of
got uncomfortable.
Again, this is around the
beginning of 2010, 2011.
They go, can we really
have 100% of all
of our food and packaging
be certifiably sustainable
by 2020?
We had a goal for 100%
sustainable fish, and coffee,
and palm oil, things like that.
And we had just opened
up Vietnam, for example.
They're like, are we going to
be able to do this in Vietnam?
And anyway, there's a whole
lot of risk adverseness
in the room.
And I was asked to go back to
the team and make it less bold.
And so I was very
downtrodden leaving the room.
But I talked to my team--
the team that we--
and the team told me, go
back in and go at it again.
We didn't want to
change a thing.
And so I went back in.
I used this chart here.
And I thought I got to
approach this differently.
Because how could a company be
asking our team to be doing--
They wanted us to be a
leader on sustainability.
But then they told me in that
meeting they wanted no risk.
So I went back and said, hey,
what do you want us to be?
And it just really opened up
the conversation to a point
where they approved the goals.
So it worked.
I'm very happy.
But since then,
since I've retired,
it's amazing what
McDonald's is doing.
They've already developed
even bigger and better goals.
So they're very proud of that.
DAVID LANGERT: And I think
that leads into one thing that
became clear is with
the size and scale
that McDonald's has
through these efforts,
you can really drive
transformative change.
And you referenced a little
bit earlier the Amazon efforts.
Not only changing
the organization
to McDonald's but the industry
and the world at large.
Can you share a couple
of other examples?
BOB LANGERT: Being a leader of
sustainability in a company,
it sounds really fascinating
and interesting, which it is.
And you've got a lot
of responsibility.
But the bottom line is I'm not
really responsible for anything
either.
Because I'm not a
head of supply chain.
I'm not a head of operations.
I'm not the head of marketing.
So a lot of my role is to
work with partners and leaders
to identify what's
good for the company
that they will want to promote.
Probably the thing that
I'm really most proud of
is our company, this
framework that we developed--
one of our specific goals was to
start buying sustainable beef.
And you talk about where the
sweet spot is for McDonald's
and how it could be good for the
business and good for society.
We call that shared value,
bringing both values at once.
And we had a team
of people come in--
NGOs from the outside world and
chief sustainability officers
from Coca-Cola, Unilever.
They came into our top
management meeting.
I was given a half day
to convince our team
that this is what we should do.
So I thought the best way to do
it is bring these outsiders in.
We asked these eight leaders
from the outside world,
what should McDonald's do?
If you were CEO for one day
and had to make one decision,
what would you do?
They all said, you
should work on beef.
Make beef more sustainable.
Your brand is beef.
Beef has environmental
health impacts.
For McDonald's global
footprint-- you know,
the carbon footprint for
McDonald's-- it's 75% in supply
chain, and it's mostly
coming from livestock.
So I was amazed that
our company agreed
to set a goal for starting to
buy it when we didn't even know
what the definition of it was.
And you said we have a lot
of influence and power.
We do, and we don't.
I often ask, how
much beef do we buy?
And I'll ask
different audiences.
And a lot of audiences will
say, hey, you must buy 10%, 20%,
50% of the beef in the world.
Well, we buy 2% of the
beef, which, by the way,
is still big.
DAVID LANGERT: Yep.
BOB LANGERT: But we can
not snap our fingers
and change the way beef
ranchers produce cows
and how they process them.
So what we learned
over the years is
that rather than kind of mandate
all this stuff, we collaborate.
And with beef, we used
our convening power
to create a global roundtable
for sustainable beef.
And so what we did is we
brought in the World Wildlife
Fund, an NGO.
We brought in Walmart.
We brought in the
biggest beef company
in the world called JBS and
dozens of other stakeholders
to define sustainable beef.
And it's proceeding
at a really good clip.
McDonald's Canada, as
we speak, is selling
sustainable, certified beef.
DAVID LANGERT: Wow.
BOB LANGERT: So glad
to see that happening.
And it is transformative
when you realize that you can
actually work on things
that change things beyond
McDonald's.
DAVID LANGERT: You also
mentioned that trip
to the Amazon.
This is you there.
BOB LANGERT: If I had to say
what my favorite adventure was,
that was definitely
going through the Amazon.
And I really-- to see up close
how people live in the Amazon--
I think too many
people in companies,
they don't go out and see
what really is happening.
So I think it's really,
really important
to go out and see
what's happening
with the forest and the Amazon,
go see how tomatoes are picked
in southern Florida,
go see how animals
are treated in facilities.
So that was really
a big part of what
I felt very strongly about.
DAVID LANGERT: At the
end of each chapter,
you have these Hard Knock
Nuggets, these learnings,
teachings that you end with.
You mentioned
earlier that you had
no real authority in your role.
So you were really
relying on your ability
to influence others.
Can you share some of
your tips on how you
were able to accomplish that?
BOB LANGERT: Yeah,
I think people
that work on corporate
social responsibility
and sustainability--
sometimes I think
we should be having a
title, maybe influencing
manager, influencing director,
or officer of influence.
Because I think that's a chief
skill that you have to have.
And maybe it's my next book
But in terms of how you do it--
I mean, there's books written
about how you influence others.
All I can tell you that what
I think worked for me is it
starts with developing
really good relationships.
You develop trust.
So people need to trust you.
They need to trust
you as a human being,
and also trust that whatever
you're saying and doing
is the truth.
You're going to deliver.
So it starts with trust.
I think it also
starts influencing--
I'm not sure they
teach this a whole lot.
Basically, you've got to
be a great communicator.
And I remember Jim Cantalupo.
He was one of our great
CEOs at McDonald's.
He turned around the
business in 2001.
I asked him after two years of
turning it around, I said, Jim,
like, what did you learn
that surprised you?
He goes, I can't believe
that 99% of the job
is communicating.
And so that always stuck with
me But I think being persuasive.
And I remember
reading this book--
and I recommend it
to your watchers
here-- it's called "Made
to Stick" by Chip Heath.
I just read that book.
And I go, so many
people on sustainability
that are pushing things.
They put forth
facts and figures.
And they kind of
think how they think,
and they're pushing
something to somebody else.
I always thought the best
way is to think how you think
and to put things into a
way that I can convince you.
You need the facts and figures.
But it's more the
story and more maybe
the emotional side that you
also need to communicate.
DAVID LANGERT: So
at this point, we
can open it up to our audience
questions, if anyone has some.
So before coming to
McDonald's, what did you do?
What was your background between
the South Side and McDonald's?
BOB LANGERT: I grew up on the
South Side of Chicago first.
And I think I'm so lucky to
do the work I ended up doing.
Because I always say I'm
a product of the 1960s.
And I have an older
brother, four years older.
You know him well.
He's your father.
[LAUGHTER]
And he actually led the way.
We used to tape record.
I mean, this is back
in 1964, 1966, 1968.
We used to record all the
songs, and play tapes,
and make a top 10 list.
But I just remember I loved
the music of the '60s,
that revolutionary take.
You know, the Bob Dylan, the
Neil Young, the Crosby, Stills,
Nash and Young, Jimi Hendrix,
and this whole explosion
of peace, and
justice, anti-Vietnam.
To be honest with you, I
feel like that's who I was.
I was an activist at heart.
But hey, I went to college.
I got married.
I had kids.
There weren't jobs like
this when I came out
of school in 1978
to try to do good
in society and the company.
So OK, that was kind
of a hidden side of me.
And to answer your question more
specifically, believe or not,
I was in charge of truck
drivers and getting
food and packaging delivered
to the McDonald's restaurants.
And so back in '88--
1988 and 1989, McDonald's
is under attack.
Well, we're a symbol of
a disposable society.
There's too much
waste being produced
by all of our packaging.
Remember it as polyst--
well, you're too young.
For older people, remember
the polystyrene foam clamshell
that people hated.
So for the first time
ever, McDonald's was
a despised, evil company.
And there was nobody
working on the environments.
And for some reason,
they plucked me out
and said, hey, Bob,
you're in charge of saving
the polystyrene clamshell.
We tried to recycle it.
I got rid of CFCs in packaging.
And that was my beginning.
And that's when I
realized how lucky I
was to get something
that maybe was
inside me waiting to come out.
And I got to do it
through business.
DAVID LANGERT: It's
somewhat ironic.
Because your goal was
to save the clamshell.
And--
BOB LANGERT: I didn't succeed.
DAVID LANGERT: [LAUGHS] But it
opened your eyes to other ways
that it keeps--
BOB LANGERT: We
couldn't save that.
Because people couldn't see
the value in that polystyrene
clamshell.
We spent millions of
dollars trying to save it.
I'm glad we didn't.
It was such an obstacle
in the way of our image.
DAVID LANGERT: Yeah.
BOB LANGERT: And
really, we ended up
working on this project with
the Environmental Defense Fund.
And just to tell that
story real shortly.
We were the first
company to work
with a famous environmental
group, the Environmental
Defense Fund, back in 1990.
Today, corporations
and NGOs work together.
But that was like the first
big one that happened.
And we worked for six months,
and we reduced about 42 things
to reduce, reuse, recycle
within McDonald's.
And we measured.
During the decade
of the '90s, we
reduced 300 million
pounds of waste.
And we got a White House award.
I was actually in the Rose
Garden getting an award.
Whereas two years earlier,
we were in the doghouse.
So we came a long way.
DAVID LANGERT: That's awesome.
BOB LANGERT: So I cut
my teeth that way.
It's really good to cut your
teeth early on with such
a win-win-win thing.
And that's how I see it
should be for companies today.
This battle to do good--
it should be less
a battle and more
of an opportunity
for businesses.
DAVID LANGERT: I think one
thing that became clear
as you're working
with these critics
is I think was easy for you to
work on environmental issues
because it was a
passion point of yours.
But there are times when
specifically on the animal
side, you admittedly didn't
know much about animal treatment
and even disagreed with
viewpoints like you're not
a vegan, you eat meat.
And so how were you able to
bridge that gap when you're
coming from a different
viewpoint of someone
you're working
with that's really
challenging you to be better?
BOB LANGERT: Well, I always
try to find common ground.
So I can find common ground
with those people that
are involved with
the environment
and protecting the planet.
I can find people that are
for social justice and better
conditions for people working.
And I'm all for good
animal treatment.
But the issue here was animal
rights versus animal welfare.
And there's a real
big difference there.
So yeah, I had a hard
time wrapping my head
around the animal
rights people that
wanted animals to be at a
similar level as human beings.
But I didn't have
to wrestle too hard.
Because the bottom line
is animal welfare--
a little bit different.
I spoke about Dr.
Temple Grandin.
We would do all of our
work to protect animals.
There was nobody more
passionate about making
sure they didn't suffer pain,
and suffering, and abuse.
But at the end of
the day, you know,
we'd have dinner at a
steakhouse that night
versus looking at
the animals like they
don't belong in
the system at all.
And I respect people
that are vegetarians.
But that's not what
McDonald's is about.
And so I think
there's common ground
to be found, even in these
thorny issues that you
refer to.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I'm just curious to hear
if it's challenging,
with so many franchisees
around the world--
how you keep your corporate
social responsibility goals
the same at a corporate level
and then also at the franchise
level, if that's been
challenging or something you
guys have had to focus on.
BOB LANGERT: Yeah,
McDonald's is owned by 5,000
independent owner/operators.
And I think today it's
getting closer to 95%
of the whole system is run by
independent business people.
So by definition, you
can't force anything
down their throats.
And even the great
owner/operators
of McDonald's, the
reason they're so good
is they're entrepreneurial.
They don't necessarily
like to be told what to do.
And that's part of our success.
So it is a challenge.
So how do you work with that?
The way I work with
it is number one,
you've got to get something
going that people get behind.
And what I'm really
happy, even since I left,
McDonald's has
made sustainability
almost part of their brand.
They call it now scale for good.
Our owner/operators
are on the front lines.
They hear all these
complaints and people
want us to be a better company.
And we think we're good already.
So in general, the programs
that I was working on
and they're working on today--
they welcome that.
The owner/operators want
to pressure relief of not
being perceived as a bad guy.
And plus, you've got a set of
goals that are actually doable
and they can relate to.
So McDonald's is setting goals,
back then and even today,
to reduce waste, recycle more,
to have recyclable packaging,
and supply chain.
So many of these things--
about half the things you
do in a restaurant in terms
of how you train your people.
But so much is done in
supply chain, for example.
I mean, the biggest impact from
McDonald's is in supply chain.
And the owner/operators
trust McDonald's
to do the right things there.
And I spoke about a
lot of the examples.
So I think the franchise
system is a strength.
But it does make it a
little bit more difficult.
AUDIENCE: First a
comment, then a question.
Bob, thanks for coming.
I wanted to compliment
you on your choice
of cover art for the book.
I think you really nailed it.
I know you were considering
a number of options.
Great job.
As far as the question--
clearly, your
influence has impacted
McDonald's in a massively
positive way over the years.
I was just curious.
Not everything in
corporations is roses.
So biggest challenge,
or biggest regret,
or biggest thing you worked
on that you were hoping to get
done that couldn't--
just didn't take--
BOB LANGERT: The list is long.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
I think at a macro level, what
probably disappointed-- like,
if I was frustrated
about my work
at McDonald's, it would
be probably the decision
making process.
It just got worse and
worse as we got bigger.
Sometimes I felt I had
to go to 30, 40 people
to say yes to something.
I had to go to another 20 or 30
that could-- one no knocks it
out of the box.
So I think we became
too bureaucratic.
When I retire, the new
CEO, Steve Easterbrook,
was going to shake that
all up and get decision
making more streamlined.
I haven't lived the last four
years to know what that's like.
But from what I read,
I think they're doing
a much better job of that.
I think another thing
that frustrates me--
if I had to relive the
McDonald's history--
like, I thought about this
when I was reading the book--
we didn't come up with
our strategic framework
that I spoke about until 2014.
These issues started to
percolate in 1988 and 1990.
So you can say that
we were awfully
late to join the bandwagon.
I wish we would have
developed our framework 10,
15 years earlier.
But it's never too late.
And that's my message
to the broader audience
today and all companies.
Just don't be sitting
back afraid of this.
Get going on it now and
develop your strategy.
Companies should develop
what they stand for.
They shouldn't be sitting
back waiting for criticism
to come in.
Develop your own goals,
what you want to stand for.
Do it, communicate, and
keep that process going.
AUDIENCE: What is your
experience with people
who view sustainability
altruistically versus necessary
for PR?
BOB LANGERT: Well, I think--
if I understand
your question, it's
looking at sustainability
through an altruistic lens
versus--
AUDIENCE: People who maybe
view it as something that is
in their hearts the right
thing to do versus, yeah,
we have to do it because it
looks poorly if we don't.
BOB LANGERT: That's an
interesting question.
Because you know, that's part
of the journey that we were on.
I worked for a company
that the reason
that we did a lot of this
stuff before in history
is that our company really
wanted to do the right thing.
I would go into meetings
at McDonald's-- this is
in the '90s and 2000s--
tough issues.
All the questions
I was being asked
were, what's the
right thing to do?
And what the cost of
it would be talked
about a little bit later.
But feeling good about it
isn't good enough in a company.
And back in the old days, it
used to be just philanthropy.
So I really think at a higher
level than feeling good
about it is a company should
be looking at it as actually
good for their business.
It should be like
more mercenary.
I mean, David, you
talked about used
to be that the only goal of
business was to make a profit.
But I think profit and
purpose go together.
And the better
companies are going
to see that sooner versus later.
And you should do
it for both reasons.
You should do it because
it's in your heart.
I think most people that work
for companies want to do good,
and you should unleash
that in your organization.
But the best way to unleash
it is you actually--
it comes from the C-Suite.
You have people working for it.
I'll give you an example
of how integrated this
is into McDonald's today.
During most of my
time at McDonald's--
30 years or so working on it--
I was a staff of one many years.
Sometimes I had
one or two people
working for me along the way.
It got to be a little
bit more and more.
But since we
established a framework,
they've got over 40 people with
sustainability in their job
description around the
world, which really tells you
that it's integrated, not
as a nice thing to do,
but more as a way to
grow the business.
AUDIENCE: What's
the single thing
we can encourage consumers to
do within this category to make
a difference on sustainability?
BOB LANGERT: We never
solved the riddle in my time
there in terms of getting the
consumer directly involved.
But I think that's changing.
Because what's changing is the
brand, the power of the brand.
One of the things that we were
trying to solve at McDonald's
is McDonald's brand health.
Back when Jim Skinner was
CEO, back in about 2008, 2009,
we had a very discouraging
trend at McDonald's.
Our business was
growing like this.
These are the charts that
we've thrown up on the walls.
And our brand health
was going like this.
So we learned through
studying brand health.
For instance, we had 42
indicators for brand health.
About 21 of them were long term.
And almost every one of those
21 were related to some aspect
of sustainability-- how
you treat your people,
how you treat the environment,
your supply chain,
are you ethical--
questions like that.
And so what we learned is that
consumers around the world
really cared about these issues.
Now, do they want to pay more?
Probably not.
But in terms of the
brand reputation,
they want a company to do that.
And we also learned--
part of the reason that we got a
strategy going at McDonald's is
that our researchers said
that for every one percentage
increase in brand health, we
would get 2% increase in sales.
But it takes three to five
years to achieve that.
So it takes kind of
a long term effort.
So I think you're seeing more of
that now through companies like
McDonald's.
I've noticed more
visibility of this.
Because I think companies
like McDonald's are
seeing that it does
impact their brand.
They've got to put
money behind it
so that consumers can see it.
DAVID LANGERT: In the
book, you talk about the--
or even here today-- you talked
about the aversion to risk.
And some of that stems
from a missed target.
So what advice would you give
if you fall short of the goals
that you set for yourself,
and how would you
handle that situation?
BOB LANGERT: I think that's
one of the things that
stops companies from
doing a bold goal.
Like, what if we
don't get there?
Are we going to end up in jail?
We had people at
McDonald's that thought,
oh, if we don't
achieve this goal,
I'm really going
to get in trouble.
And there is a certain
element to that, believe me.
I mean, when you put
a goal out there,
you've got to give it a
sincere effort to get there.
One of the things that hurt
my efforts at McDonald's was
early on--
this was about 2000-- we
made this announcement
to get out of trans fatty
acids in our cooking oil.
And we said we'd do it in
about three years' time.
And we failed to
meet that deadline.
And we ended up getting
a lawsuit of some sort
and settling for
$10 million or so.
We ended up getting rid of
the TFAs in our cooking oil,
but it took a couple
of years later.
And it always left a
stain on the company.
We were like, well, why set
a goal when somebody could
come around and go after us?
But I think to
answer your question
more directly, what you need to
do is be very open and honest.
And what we've learned
and other companies
have learned-- if you set a
recycling goal, and it's 50%,
and all you do is
achieve at 40%,
keep ongoing communication.
Here's what we're doing, and
here's where we're failing.
Here's where we
need some more help.
Just being more open
and honest about
it is a way to share the
experience with consumers.
And I think the
critics and NGOs--
they encourage companies.
They'd rather see you
try and maybe fail
a little bit along the way
versus not even try at all.
DAVID LANGERT: Last
question I'll ask
is what excites you about
corporate social responsibility
and sustainability today?
BOB LANGERT: Well,
what really excites
me is how I see the younger
people getting involved.
I mean, I'm just so impressed.
For instance, I'm impressed
with the team at McDonald's,
the people that are there.
There's a few more of them,
as I mentioned before.
But they're-- at the age that I
was at, they're smarter than I
am.
They're go-getters.
They know how to
work with people.
And I speak a lot at different
colleges and universities.
There's so many
people now that when
they go through
MBA schools, they
want to make a difference in the
organizations that they join.
And now they have
an outlet for that.
And so seeing, I
would say, the CEOs
of my generation in
terms of how they really
looked at sustainability--
I would say, in general, I
give them a flunking grade.
More of them looked at it as a
problem versus an opportunity.
Whereas I see the younger
executives coming up today--
I have a lot of hope.
I mean, who's leading
the charge in the--
so take carbon footprint
and climate change.
We hear a lot about that.
But who's leading the charge?
It's not governments.
But you've got companies
every day making commitments,
McDonald's included.
And I think that's where
leadership is going to come.
And it's going to come stronger
with the next generation
of leaders.
DAVID LANGERT: Excellent.
Well, thanks for
joining us, Bob.
And thanks,
everyone, for coming.
BOB LANGERT: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]